schöne neue welt sag ich nur sebastian
pufpaff ist pressesprecher des bka das
bundeskriminalamt am sie eine erklärung
warum kommt da so wenig widerstand von
den bürgern der bürger erwecke der
bürger was medial bürger der bürger will
drei warme mahlzeiten zweimal die woche
über die mutti und vielleicht einmal im
monat zwischen mehr bilder gar nicht
welche es ist kein hexenwerk erstmal
brauchen gesetze zum datenschutz immer
einen möglichst langen bescheuerten
namen wo man schon im mittelteil ein fan
ihr gesetz zur förderung des
elektronischen identitätsnachweises
letzten donnerstag durch den bundestag
gepeitscht hat keine sau gemerkt wie
eine dünne er lief bei rtl 2 eine
wiederholung von frauentausch diese
irgendwas verpennt haben sie garantiert
den neunten märz da hat der bundestag
nämlich nach mitternacht das
videoüberwachungs verbesserungs gesetz
verabschiedet das wort ist beim scrabble
der apfel unter killer
dabei ist das noch nicht mal der ganze
name lesen sie wie das ding in voller
länge
setz entwurf zur änderung des
bundesdatenschutzgesetzes erhöhung der
sicherheit in öffentlich zugänglich
großflächigen anlagen und im
öffentlichen personenverkehr durch
optisch elektronische einrichtungen
bitte haben sie im bogen ein etwas
kleineres hat die deutsche sprache wie
ich erfolg gebracht
nimm das goethe
endlich viel mehr videoüberwachung im
öffentlichen raum
jetzt habe ich also irgendwann die
biometrischen daten aller deutschen in
einer art 180 millionen fachwissen auf
einem usb stick und dankte für den video
kameras kann ich dann immer sehen was
jede einzelne fresse so macht das ich
nicht
[Applaus]
erich wir machen das hier auch für dich
natürlich alles schlimmer als bei george
orwell am bahnhof südkreuz in berlin los
bei dem pilotprojekt da erkennt eine
software selbstständig abnormales
verhalten
darunter versteht die bundespolizei zum
beispiel zitat personen die sich
auffällig lange auf einem bahnsteig
aufhalten lassen abnormale scheiße warum
sollte irgendwer lange auf einem
bahnsteig rund chf leiden ein zug der
deutschen bahn hat verspätung
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
wir lachen ja aber ihr möchtet ich
möchte doch nicht mit allen meinen daten
ständig im öffentlichen raum erkennbar
sein
das kann ich mir vorstellen dass manche
software macht das spaß ihre
biometrischen sachen auswirkt haben mit
dem gesicht er was am rande zu tun wird
trotzdem alles aufgezeichnet
wissen sie noch neulich bei der
konfirmation ihres sohns wie sie danach
der kirche mein fahrrad durch den wald
ja
hat mich gerade warum war ich denn da
schon wieder nackt ja abnormale ich sage
nur abnormales verhalten aber kopf hoch
her werke steht ja nicht bei facebook
[Applaus]